was war ihr erster gedanke hofreiter als
sie das gelesen haben in der emma und
dann veröffentlicht überall was sie was
haben sie gedacht als sie von diesen
gedanken gehört haben erstmalig
dass wir einfach in mitteleuropa
westdeutschland in ganz westeuropa das
problem haben dass wir seit vielen
vielen jahren glauben immer besser zur
ist was in mittelosteuropa was europa
sinnvoll und gut ist ich dachte mir die
typische paternalistische deutsche
arroganz die wir seit jahrzehnten und
ganz traditionell den ländern und
menschen gegenüber bringen die zwischen
deutschland und russland liegen und
dementsprechend heftig waren auch die
reaktionen aus osteuropa aus der ukraine
frau schwarzer herr hofreiter wirft
ihnen das ist schon einigermaßen
spektakulär als feministin
paternalistische arroganz vor
ja weniger mehr wirft das den bisherigen
bisher verantwortlichen politikern vor
also kanzlerin merkel seit 2005 und all
den anderen außenminister steinmeier und
so weiter und da wunder ich mich herum
ich finde sie unterschätzen dann doch
das engagement und die bemühung dieser
politiker er tätig der frühere osteuropa
berater von herrn kohl er hat gerade
gesagt der einzige europäische politiker
der noch mit putin wahrscheinlich reden
könnte wäre merkel und das hat etwas
damit zu tun dass es da eben doch lange
keinen kontakt gegeben hat der immerhin
1 gebracht hat frieden das ist schon mal
etwas
und in diesen 20 jahren ist viel
passiert auf allen seiten bei uns und
auch bei putin und putin war vermutlich
von 20 oder vor 10 oder 15 jahren nicht
derselbe der heute ist jetzt auf jeden
fall haben wir die sehr reale drohung
eines atomkrieges und da müssen wir sehr
genau abwägen die stadt an den kopf
hofreiter
eben genau die bestätigung dessen was
ich gesagt habe dass man nicht wahrnimmt
was in diesen regionen passiert nämlich
wer hatte den frieden in den regionen
hatten die menschen keinen frieden sie
dürfen einzelne vergessen 2008 ist
gerade überfallen worden und sind
bereits teile aus einem souveränen
unabhängigen demokratischen mit vielen
problemen behafteten lande
ausgeschnitten worden sie interessiert
sich nach asien 2014 ist die ukraine das
erste mal überfallen worden und dann
haben wir uns immer nur den kopf das
sind der krim kein schuss gefallen ist
aber bis zum zweiten überfall auf die
ukraine am 24 februar diesen jahres sind
da irgendwas zwischen 14.000 15.000
menschen in den köpfen gestorben da gab
es keinen frieden und was haben wir 2015
macht das bundesrepublik wir haben gegen
den massiven protest der baltischen
staaten der ukraine
polens die verträge für nord stream zwei
unterschrieben und die haben uns damals
gesagt ihr täuscht euch in putins das
was ihr glaubt dass ihr damit frieden
wieder bekommt den wir gar nicht haben
das wird genau das gegenteil sein er
wird sich ermutigt fühlen er wird sagen
ah 2008 an sie nicht richtig reagiert
2014 danach haben sie nicht richtig
reagiert als sich menschen hier in
deutschland zum beispiel im tiergarten
ermorden ablassen als ich versucht habe
menschen in großbritannien ermorden zu
lassen das hat sie nicht richtig gestört
und deshalb wenn ich den nächsten andere
staaten werde ich wieder davon kommen
nicht putin hat uns immer angelogen über
taktische fragen und vielleicht linker
sonntag und sein strategisches ziel
haben uns nicht angelogen das russische
reich wieder zu und deshalb es ist ein
schönes beispiel zu sagen dass wir in
den letzten jahren frieden haben dass
man einfach genau die probleme der
menschen aus europa ignorieren nämlich
einen einen krieg 15.000 menschen das
leben gekostet haben auch keine ist kann
man etwas frieden wird sein das kann man
nur dann als frieden bezeichnen wenn man
diese region ignoriert